officials say this was the last resort
unable to safely remove the derailed
train cars carrying toxins and fearing
an explosion at any moment emergency
crews decided on a controlled burn
Tuesday Ohio's Governor had warned
everyone living within one and a half
kilometers to evacuate
urging
everyone in this area
uh actually ordering them to leave
staying could have meant skin Birds lung
damage or even death vinyl chloride a
material used in Plastics is linked to
cancer phosgene was used as a biological
weapon in World War One the rail
operator Norfolk Southern said Tuesday's
controlled release of the chemicals from
the derailment was a success and
residents are no longer in immediate
Danger
yeah little phrase
deaf ran a big black horse that's what
it felt like I'm seriously really dead
the evacuation order covers more than 2
000 residents some people staying
overnight at a shelter run by the Red
Cross
the Ohio National Guard and state police
are Manning blockades at every entrance
into town while workers and hazmat suits
are inside the containment zone laboring
for about a week to clear the derailment
government scientists say that the air
quality here is currently safe though
it's anyone's guess when people will be
returned will be allowed to return home
yesterday I had to go home to pick up
prescriptions
the creek by my house had a very very
strong chemical smell to it I went in my
house it was worse the Environmental
Protection Agency is monitoring the air
and water quality and will continue to
study the disasters possible long-term
impact
Heidi Joe Castro Al Jazeera New
Palestine Ohio